estoy aquí con ustedes para recordar un
momento histórico justamente hoy este 19
de septiembre de
de este año 2020 estamos cumplido 35
años del terremoto de la ciudad de
mexico que fue un terremoto devastador y
por supuesto los que despertamos en
aquel entonces despertamos con la
incertidumbre de un movimiento que no
entendíamos y descubrimos la ciudad de
la destrucción minuto a minuto a partir
de puros rumores y a partir de movernos
en circunstancias bastante complicadas
hace varios varios años - dices cuáles
son las lecciones aprendidas o que a
méxico le faltan todavía por aprender y
las medidas que se han tomado después de
esos dos terremotos
mira aprendimos bastantes cosas y hemos
incorporado no solamente protocolos y
simulacros permanentes en la ciudad
médico tenemos alguna alerta sísmica que
nos da un minuto previo antes de
cualquier otro terremoto o sismo está
por encima de los 67 grados richter y
hoy nos permite salvar vidas por
supuesto que hemos aprendido también
cómo protegernos que tener en casa las
construcciones todo el sistema de
construcción de la ciudad amigo se
modificó y la hemos librado mucho mejor
en los últimos sismos en la ciudad de
mexico